good morning John last week the
consensus to my question about why we
like to dance the songs you don't
understand the words to that we can hear
the passion in the words but then we can
project our individual circumstances
onto their like blank canvas what you
thought was really quite nice and made
sense but then I got obsessed with what
the words actually meant I recruited
some translators through Twitter not to
translate word for word but to translate
the meaning and then I crammed that
meaning or attempt to do into like a
cover of the song in English but with
the original meaning yeah I'm probably
about to ruin these songs for you by
eliminating your ability to project your
subconscious onto the nonsense of their
words I don't care though deal day she's
woman pretty and nice a classy girl
drinking double latte on ice a girl who
start to keep the club up whenever the
night arrives and girl who's got that
kind of spice
aha
won't ever do
oh forgot Gangnam style Gangnam is a
district in Seoul that is like a super
wealthy district and a lot of people
that don't live there try to act like
they live there and that can result in
people struggling terribly to maintain
that image and we have this problem in
America too Gangnam style at first abuse
be celebrated that culture that it turns
out in fact that it's mocking the
culture of materialism and wealth so
that's pretty cool
then dance listen thank you by this
antenna it depicts about into - it's
gotta be okay now listen this is the
only verse that was in the version of
the Macarena that we heard and it sounds
pretty innocuous but then the next verse
in the original version of the Macarena
Macarena spy friend gets drafted into
the Army and then she listens to her
body and has sex with two of his friends
and then wants to go shopping a lot and
turns out to choose just a terrible
person so dance lets me pick out so just
Gallina again your big strong man no
pressure for me just go and you see yo
if you don't don't don't you take me you
don't want to take me no you're
without the affection love under the
linden tree remind me
this guy keeps going this girl who's
presumably his ex or current girlfriend
she won't pick up so he's leaving
messages he keeps talking about how cool
he is and relating himself to all these
epic Romanian cultural icons and then
he's just wailing about how she's
leaving him and relating their love to a
Romanian epic poem it's very sad so
dance party down this is so much that
I'm chicken and I'm dizzy in a car to my
knees you will need to sleep with the
snowfalls in the winter
only for you your eyes only for me
tomorrow
I thought it was gonna be get down a
shake it in a shaker then I do a little
dance instead she a prison is singing
about the eternal blood that she made to
her dead or otherwise lost lover and now
is alone in the cold cold winter which
according to one of the translators is a
Japanese symbol for a perfect thing in
an imperfect setting which I guess would
be her perfect pledge to a dead guy get
down how's it translated Soulja Boy has
lots of sag Soulja Boy can really dance
Soulja Boy is really great and women are
for sex that watch me dance yeah so I
never wanted dance to that song again I
apologize for ruining all these thongs
for you thank you to my Romanian and
Korean and Japanese and Spanish
translators and thank you for Michael
Aranda for mixing and auto-tuning those
because I can't do the things that those
people do and John I'll see you on
Tuesday